Write the equation of the
line that has a slope of 1/3
and contains the point
negative 12, negative 14/3.
So the equation of
a line we can write
as y is equal to mx plus b.
This is in slope-intercept
form, where m is our slope
and b right over here
is our y-intercept.
And they have actually
given us our slope.
Our slope, they tell us, is 1/3.
So we know that m
is going to be 1/3.
So we know that y is
equal to 1/3 x plus b.
And so now we just
have to solve for b.
And the way we can solve for
b is that we know this line
contains the point
negative 12, negative 14/3.
So when x is equal
to negative 12,
y is equal to negative 14/3.
So let's write that down.
Negative 14/3 is going
to be equal to 1/3--
our slope-- times
our x value, which
is negative 12-- times
negative 12-- and then plus b.
So when x is
negative 12, we know
that y is equal
to negative 14/3.
And we also know that
the slope is 1/3.
That's the m in mx plus b.
So now we can just solve for b.
The left-hand side-- I'll just
leave it as negative 14/3--
is equal to 1/3
times negative 12.
1/3 times negative
12 is negative 4,
so this is negative 4, plus b.
Let me write the plus
b in that same color
that I had started it with.
Plus b.
It looks like a yellow color.
And now, to isolate b
on the right-hand side,
we can add 4 to both sides.
I want to get rid
of this negative 4.
So let's add 4 to both sides.
So plus 4, plus 4-- on
the right-hand side,
we're left with just a b.
b is equal to-- on the
left-hand side, we have 4.
4 I can rewrite.
Because I'm going to have
to add 4 to negative 14/3.
So I want a common denominator.
4 is the same thing as 12/3.
So 4 is 12/3, minus 14/3.
So I just want to be clear.
I just rewrote the 4 as 12/3.
So 12/3 minus 14/3, or
negative 14/3 plus 12/3,
is going to give us-- well, we
have the same denominator of 3.
So we're going to have 3.
12 minus 14 is negative 2.
So we have negative
2/3 is equal to b.
So the equation of the
line we figured out.
They gave us the slope.
And now we just figured
out the y-intercept
using this information
right over here.
So the equation of
our line is going
to be y is equal to 1/3 x-- we
got the 1/3 from the problem--
plus b. b is negative 2/3.
So I could just write minus 2/3.
And we are done.